>> Tucker: AT ONE OF THE
SCARIEST THINGS ABOUT THE WUHAN
CORONAVIRUS AND ONE OF THE MANY
REASONS THAT ALL OF US HAVE LONG
BEEN SO AFRAID OF IT IS HOW
LITTLE WE KNOW ABOUT IT.
EBOLA, COLORADO, OBVIOUSLY THOSE
ARE DANGEROUS DISEASES AND HAVE
KILLED MILLIONS, BUT ON THE
WHOLE FUNDAMENTALLY ANYWAY, WE
KNOW HOW EASILY THEY SPREAD AND
HOW DEADLY THEY ARE.
THIS DISEASE BY CONTRAST IS
ENTIRELY NEW.
IT’S LITERALLY A NOVEL
CORONAVIRUS.
EARLY ACCOUNTS SAID THE MYSTERY
ILLNESS COMING FROM CENTRAL
CHINA COULD BE TRANSMITTED FAR
MORE EASILY THAN THE FLU AND THE
DEATH RATE WAS ARE MARKEDLY
HIGH.
SOME REPORTS SUGGESTED IT COULD
KILL TWO, THREE, FIVE, EVEN 8%
OF ALL THOSE WHO GOT IT.
WORST-CASE SCENARIO PREDICTED
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
WOULD DIE.
OF THE PUBLIC WAS HORRIFIED AND
STILL ARE.
BUT HOW AFRAID SHOULD THEY BE?
MANY PEOPLE ARE STILL DYING IN
THIS PANDEMIC INCLUDING HERE IN
UNITED STATES.
BEYOND THAT FACT WE STILL DON’T
HAVE THE NUMBERS WE NEED TO
FULLY UNDERSTAND WHAT’S
HAPPENING AROUND US.
TOO FEW PEOPLE HAVE BEEN TESTED.
AND YET THERE ARE SOME
SUGGESTIONS OF GOOD NEWS AND WE
WANT TO BRING THEM TO YOU.
BETWEEN MARCH 22ND AND APRIL 4TH
A TOTAL OF 215 PREGNANT WOMEN
DELIVERED BABIES AT NEW YORK
PRESBYTERIAN HOSPITAL.
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THESE WOMEN
WAS SCREENED FOR THE
CORONAVIRUS.
IT TURNED OUT THAT 33 OF THEM
HAD IT, THAT’S MORE THAN 15% OF
THE TOTAL GROUP.
OF THE INFECTED, 29 OF THEM COME
ABOUT 88% OF THEM HAD WOW WERE
TOTALLY ASYMPTOMATIC.
SO THINK ABOUT WHAT THAT MIGHT
MEAN IF WE EXTRAPOLATE IT
CITYWIDE.
AS OF APRIL 4TH NEW YORK HAS
MORE THAN 60,000 OF THE
CONFIRMED CASES OF THE
CORONAVIRUS AND A LITTLE OVER
2200 DEATHS.
IF MORE THAN 15% OF NEW YORK’S
POPULATION WAS INFECTED, THAT
WOULD SUGGEST A TOTAL OF
1.3 MILLION CASES IN NEW YORK
WITH ONLY ABOUT 150,000 OF THEM
SHOWING SYMPTOMS.
IN OTHER WORDS THE VIRUS WOULD
BE FAR MORE WIDESPREAD THAN WE
EXPECTED IT TO BE BUT ALSO FAR
LESS DEADLY THAN WE EXPECTED.
THE ACTUAL DEATH RATE WOULD NOT
BE THREE OR 4%, IT WOULD BE
CLOSER TO .2%.
THERE WOULD BE GREAT.
WE DON’T KNOW FOR CERTAIN THAT’S
THE CASE, 215 PEOPLE IS A SMALL
SAMPLE AND IN THIS SPECIFIC CASE
IT’S NOT A REPRESENTATIVE
SAMPLE.
HOSPITALS ARE MAJOR FACTORS FOR
TRANSMISSION OF THE CORONAVIRUS
AND PREGNANT WOMAN SPEND A LOT
OF TIME IN HOSPITALS.
THEY ARE ALSO USUALLY YOUNGER
AND HEALTHIER THAN OTHER PEOPLE
SO IT’S POSSIBLE THEY EXHIBIT
LESS SYMPTOMS.
ON THE OTHER HAND IF THIS IS NOT
THE ONLY STUDIES THAT SUGGEST
THESE TRENDS.
IN SCOTLAND THE RESEARCHERS
TESTED 500 PEOPLE THREE WEEKS
INTO THE OUTBREAK THERE AND MORE
THAN 1% TESTED POSITIVE FOR
ANTIBODIES TO CORONAVIRUS.
THAT’S 12 TIMES GREATER THAN THE
CONFIRMED CASELOAD IN THAT
COUNTRY AT THAT TIME.
12 TIMES MORE.
IN DENMARK A LITTLE OVER A MONTH
INTO THE OUTBREAK ONLY .1% OF
THE POPULATION WAS INFECTED
ACCORDING TO OFFICIAL NUMBERS.
AND YET, A SCREENING OF 1500
PEOPLE FOUND THAT 2.7% ACTUALLY
HAD ANTIBODY IS.
THAT WOULD MEAN THE TRUE DEATH
RATE FROM CORONAVIRUS THERE
MIGHT BE 127TH AS HIGH AS THEY
THOUGHT IT WAS.
IN MEANWHILE IN GERMANY THE
OFFICIAL DEATH RATE FROM
CORONAVIRUS STANDS TODAY AT
2.5%, BUT THE HORRIFYING NUMBER,
AND IT MAY BE REAL.
ON THE OTHER HAND IN THE TOWN OF
GANG GELT WHERE LARGE-SCALE
RANDOM TESTING HAS BEEN
PERFORMED THE DEATH RATE WAS
FOUND TO BE JUST .37%.
THAT’S US SEVENTH OF THE
ORIGINAL.
ALL OF THIS IS ENCOURAGING NEWS.
IF THE INFECTION IS MORE
WIDESPREAD THAN WE THOUGHT THEN
BY DEFINITION THAT MEANS THE
VIRUS IS LESS DEADLY.
THAT WOULD MEAN OUR BURDEN ON
THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM WOULD BE
LOWER THAN WE EXPECTED IT TO BE
AND WE ARE SEEING THAT.
IT MAY ALSO MEAN THAT
CORONAVIRUS MAY BE CLOSER THAN
WE KNEW TO RUNNING ITS COURSE.
THAT WOULD MEAN A LOT OF PEOPLE
HAD BEEN AFFECTED AND RECOVERED
WITHOUT EVEN KNOWING IT AND
THOSE PEOPLE COULD PAUSE AND LET
RELIEF SWEEP OVER THEM AND THEY
GET BACK TO THEIR LIVES.
ABOVE ALL, IF THESE TRENDS HOLD
IT WOULD MEAN THAT THE REST OF
US COULD BE SLIGHTLY LESS
TERRIFIED GOING FORWARD.
YES, IT’S AWFUL.
YES PEOPLE ARE DYING AND THEY
WILL CONTINUE TO DIE HERE IN THE
U.S.
BUT IT MAY NOT BE QUITE THE
PLAGUE THAT WE THOUGHT IT WAS.
THAT COULD GIVE US SOME
PERSPECTIVE.
MOST OF US WANT ALL OF THAT
BADLY.
BUT DO OUR LEADERS WANT THAT?
SOMETIMES WHEN YOU WATCH THEM
YOU BEGIN TO SUSPECT THEY ARE
SECRETLY ENJOYING OUR FEAR.
DR. JADE THAT IF TORI IS A
STANFORD PROFESSOR IS BEEN
STUDYING THE DEATH RATE.
DOCTOR, THANKS SO MUCH FOR
COMING ON.
WHAT ARE YOU CONCLUDING ABOUT
THE REAL DEATH WERE RATE FROM TH
VIRUS?
>> I THINK BASED ON THE EVIDENCE
THAT WE’VE SEEN SO FAR IT’S
ACTUALLY LOWER THAN THE INITIAL
ESTIMATES.
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
PUT AN ESTIMATE OUT THERE, AND I
THINK IT’S INITIALLY 3.4%.
IT’S VERY UNLIKELY THAT IT’S
ANYWHERE NEAR THAT, IT’S MORE
LIKELY MUCH CLOSER TO THE DEATH
RATE THEN YOU SEE HER CASE.
THE QUESTION IS WE DON’T HAVE
THE VACCINE SO IN THAT SENSE
IT’S MORE DEADLY AND MORE
WIDESPREAD THAN THE FLU.
IT OVERWHELMS HOSPITAL SYSTEMS
WHERE THE FLU DOESN’T BUT I
DON’T THINK IT’S AS DEADLY AS
PEOPLE THOUGHT.
>> Tucker: I’D KNOW IT’S VERY
HARD TO COME UP WITH ANY KIND OF
FIRM NUMBERS IN THE ABSENCE OF
WIDESPREAD TESTING, BUT DO YOU
THINK IT’S LIKELY THAT THERE ARE
LARGE NUMBERS OF AMERICANS WHO
HAVE BEEN INFECTED, RECOVERED
AND DIDN’T KNOW IT?
>> I BELIEVE THAT IS TRUE.
WE ARE GOING TO START TO KNOW
THAT VERY SOON.
I’VE BEEN WORKING ON STUDIES
WITH SOME COLLEAGUES IN OF MINE
AND ALSO A LARGE NATIONWIDE
STUDY WORKING WITH MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL EMPLOYEES, NOT JUST
ATHLETES BUT ALL THE EMPLOYEES.
VERY SOON WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A
MUCH MORE ACCURATE UNDERSTANDING
OF HOW WIDESPREAD THIS IS.
AS YOU SAID IN YOUR INTRODUCTION
WE ALSO KNOW MUCH BETTER AND HOW
DEADLY IT ACTUALLY IS.
EVIDENCE AROUND THE WORLD IS
FLOWING IN AND IT REALLY SEEMS
LIKE THERE ARE MANY, MANY CASES
OF THE CORONAVIRUS THAT WE
HAVEN’T IDENTIFIED.
MANY ORDERS OF MAGNITUDE AND
MORE PEOPLE HAVE BEEN AFFECTED
THEN WE REALIZE AND AS YOU
RIGHTLY POINTED OUT THAT MEANS
THAT THE DEATH RATE IS ACTUALLY
LOWER THAN PEOPLE REALIZE.
ALSO BY ORDERS OF MAGNITUDE.
>> Tucker: IT’S OF ONE OF THE
DESTRUCTIVE BYPRODUCTS OF THIS
PANDEMIC IS FEAR WHICH IS ITSELF
CLEARLY HURTING PEOPLE.
YOU ARE AN AMERICAN IN ADDITION
TO A RESEARCHER, AND BASED ON
THE RESEARCH YOU’VE ARE YOU MORE
OR LESS AFRAID THAN WHEN YOU
BEGIN?
>> I’M LESS AFRAID THAN WHEN I
BEGAN.
I’VE HEARD SO MANY STORIES OF
PEOPLE WHO COULDN’T HUG THEIR
GRANDKIDS, AND I THINK REALLY
THE TRUE DEATH RATE IS ONE IN A
THOUSAND, WOULD YOU NOT TELL
YOUR WIFE?
SO I’M HOPING THAT ONCE WE GET
NUMBERS IN PLACE BUT IT WILL
QUELL THE FEAR THIS OUT THERE.